à 2019 on est en 2010 note depuis pas
longtemps et bientôt mis 19 les chéris
c'est le retour du poil ah ah ah oui les
chéris ça y est c'est tombé je vous le
dis c'est le retour du poil le poil fait
son retour
puisqu'une français sur quatre ne
s'épile plus du tout non elles sont
quatre ici voilà vous faites les paris
voilà locales comme ça qu'est ce que
l'humanité fait du bien à dire il y en a
aucune qui s'épilent pas facile tu
reprends des autres après de proposer ma
part je vais vous dire la boulette et
dans le tage et j'aurais fait la
boulette et dont le et kelly c'est sous
sa moustache avait une espèce d'astérix
[Rires]
alors je vous dis donc
hessel jambes puisse parties intimes on
laisse faire la nature et on ne touche
plus à mameria alors donc j'étais dans
l'esthétique ont pu encore un truc
hypocrite chaque année on essaie de
relancer cette mode qui ne marche jamais
aucune femme va laisser ces points-là
par balles est bon vous bonjour vous est
ce que vous les cédez poil marocain
aucun poil ça veut dire sur vous il ya
aucune toile malpolis elle alors j'ai un
détecteur de toile où la raison vous
savez d'où ça vient c'est il ya eu une
période d'un petit peu féministe des
actrices américaines notamment il à
roberts la première gonnard a fait
notamment des oscars où elle a way sera
avec une robe de soirée et à la volée
les programmes je suis parti de là et on
s'est dit pas comme les actrices
américaines le fond ça va programmer
ressasser les poils sous les bras il
paraît que ça va devenir un carton
car l'école aurait tout ça mais en fait
c'est un auxiliaire d'envoi alors moi
moi je vous dit personnellement une meuf
jusqu'en mars avec une meuf mais ça et
imagine sans déconner la mocheté
tranquille tu veux un clip et la maaf tu
sais quoi
tu viens de la pécho et le matelas
malgré ça c'est un lobby féministe qui
veut que les fans soient lecorne
n'appartient pas aux hommes une femme
sur ce quart diktat matthew walker
poilbout sur vous par aucun média désire
c'est une idem pour les pour les garçons
pour moi si tu as des poils si tu as
quelque chose à cacher c'est mettre une
bâche sur une porsche ou ferrari fait
pas énormément de poids la tension s'est
totalement et n'a rien à cacher la
carrosserie est magnifique
donc celui qui a des points c'est vrai
mais qu'est ce que vous en savez vous
il a fait 96 tuera pas il ya de ça il ya
deux ans donc j'ai tout vu sans ces
effets à l'escompté fait rien on passe à
autre chose
la gâcher écoutez je suis légèrement
poilus et pour autant je n'ai rien à
cacher tête une fois j'ai voulu t
devrait être pour lui peut-être pas mais
j'ai voulu me raser une fois pour moi
pour voir mes muscles et normalement
c'est du flan big se voyait donc
[Applaudissements]